D
HE REST.ASEW CHANCE JU
CHARACTERIZED SO SEE NMATTER WH
N SEEM
RUSSIA ON IS
PUTIN IN CHECK? INSEEADVANCINGB
MO
O EVEN HOLON
TO.
'T
THEY'VE ANNEXSO THAT'E ONLY
W
AGAINST THHO THREATS WE
MOERATTACKED AND THA
VEPORTIA ANY SSLEHAD IL ABOUT D
JU T
RUSSIAITNING, WHAT IS  TDIGNITKH
ON OS
MESSAGAN SEEMINGLY
AMONE
W, WATCH
WHOLE THININCLUD
MINUTES THAT TTOIT IM TILLE CA
INMPAREDR SPEECHES
HE
THEY LNDF NERVOUSLK VERY EHU
LOAROUND.
HIM, YOU KNOW, THEAUSE, BUI THIN
THE WAR,T' E  -IT
'S ,ST ORL
ING A RUSSIA THAT WI BE ENED ANA
BE PT BOASTINGTHIS U
ANNEXATION.
BUT INTERNALLY, WHAT D
SUPPOSE HE IIS
BY RETREATING?THEN, IS
>> T
HE PROJECTED'T THINK
THAT
LOSING.
D  HE ATLEFIEL HE'CRITICIZED, WH
MOBILIZIO
BADLY.PEOP A
BUT I THINK HEOM THINKE POURS E
UNDERSTAND HOW INEFFECTIVELY THE
TARY HAS PERFORMTILL, IT'SY OUS
RIGHT, BECAUSE PUTIN SAID IN HIS
SPEE THAT THERE WAS PRECEDENT R
WEAPONS D ERD THE
U.S. AND JAPAN.
HECTION
TO THAT.
>>E BEENHABEASEEEAR THAT THERE
THAT HULCOS ANULR AT THE CONSEQ
AVED THAT
DIREO THE .
WE DO NOSE
INE LIMITED
77EATABOO, BUTPO>>USLY DO YOU T.
TO TE T N'T THYO
INTIMIDATE EVEE  TES TO TEL
UKRAINIANS TO GIVE UP D SI